Horror hit factory Blumhouse has returned
to theaters with a mind-bending sequel to
Happy Death Day and this time, everything's
different.
While the spacetime-twisting tale may be a
little bit headier than its predecessor, there's
no reason to be caught out of the loop.
Let's break down the ending of Happy Death
Day 2U.
The first Happy Death Day follows Tree Gelbman's
journey from a stuck-up sorority mean girl
to a sympathetic, take-charge survivor.
It was a satisfying character arc, told in
charming fashion, feeling like Groundhog Day
by way of Friday the 13th.
"Hey, uh, you know I don't think you should
be taking that many.
You could, uh, you could die."
"If only it were that easy."
In the first movie, the mechanism that causes
Tree to go into a day-repeating time loop
is never revealed, appearing simply as a mystical
phenomenon that serves to drive the story.
But director Christopher Landon has long promised
that an explanation for the loop is hidden
in the movie, set up in advance to be explored
in the sequel.
As he claimed in an interview with Insider,
"The whole idea for my sequel is actually
already in this movie.
It's hiding in plain sight."
Many viewers took the director's lead, concocting
their own theories about the loop's origins.
The movie's emphasis on Tree's deceased mother,
as well as their long-lost tradition of blowing
out birthday candles together, gave rise to
the hypothesis that Tree's mom had something
to do with the loop, with her spirit somehow
manipulating time from beyond the grave to
keep her daughter safe.
But Happy Death Day 2U firmly debunks those
theories, revealing a source for the phenomenon
that's more science-fictiony in nature than
anyone saw coming.
In what feels like a wild departure from the
original, Happy Death Day 2U reveals that
Tree's time-twisting journey was caused by
a literal time machine, located in a science
lab on the Bayfield University campus.
The device is partially the invention of Carter's
roommate Ryan, the oafish goober from the
first movie with a tendency of barging in
every time Tree wakes up.
While the first movie paints Ryan as awkward
and sex-obsessed, the sequel reveals his hidden
depths, as well as an intellect that would
do good by Doc Brown himself.
The opening act of the sequel reveals that
Ryan is in the process of developing the time
machine with a team of fellow student scientists
named Samar and Sarah.
While they haven't perfected the device just
yet — and who knows how they're funding
this thing — the team soon discovers that
it's fully capable of disturbing the fabric
of space-time.
The time loops turn out to be an unintentional
side effect of their machine, meaning that
of all people, it was actually Ryan who was
responsible for Tree's most bogus birthday
journey.
She's not happy about it.
The lab students who developed the machine
call it the Sisyphus quantum cooling reactor,
or "Sissy" for short.
The name is an on-the-nose reference to the
Greek legend of Sisyphus, a man punished by
the gods to spend each day rolling a boulder
up a hill, never quite reaching the top.
As viewers of the first Happy Death Day know,
it's a trial that Tree can definitely relate
to.
"I am so done with this sh-",
The introduction of Sissy marks a clear pivot
from the first movie's horror trappings toward
straight-up science-fiction.
But Happy Death Day 2U also leans into a more
romantic angle than its acerbic slasher predecessor,
becoming more of a sci-fi rom-com than the
Scream-like original.
When the machine is activated to kick off
the movie's second act, it sends Tree into
a parallel dimension, in which her relationships
with the people around her are ever-so-slightly
askew.
The changes are small but significant, forcing
Tree to reevaluate her own life, and what
she wants out of it.
While the first dimension's Carter is single
until he meets Tree, the second dimension
version is happily dating Danielle, a rival
of Tree's and the alpha dog of her sorority.
In Tree's world, her mother has been dead
for the last three years, but in the second
world that she ends up in, her mother is still
alive.
As a result of these change-ups, the tension
in the story this time around isn't so much
"will Tree survive" as it is "will love prevail,"
with the Babyface villain's killing spree
being left somewhat in the background.
In the sequel, Tree's biggest challenge is
figuring out whether she wants to live in
a reality with her resurrected mother, or
go back to her original dimension, where she'd
just begun what could end up being a loving,
long-term relationship with Carter.
Much like Scream, Cabin in the Woods, and
other winking works of meta-fiction, the characters
in Happy Death Day 2U are aware of the fact
that they seem to be living through the plot
of a movie.
In this case, parallels are drawn with Back
to the Future Part II, the time-hopping adventure
sequel from 1989.
That movie saw Marty McFly not just revisiting
the past, but also the plot of the previous
movie, intersecting with the older narrative
in new and unexpected ways.
On top of the Back to the Future sequel being
surprisingly relevant to the movie's plot,
Happy Death Day 2U also sports a few references
to the sci-fi series.
Examples of these tips of the hat include
a wood chipper from "Biff's Tree Removal"
that Tree cheerfully tosses herself into at
the end of one loop, as well as the fateful
speed of 88 mph she attains during one desperate
death behind the wheel.
"When this baby hits 88 mph, you're gonna
see some serious s---."
While it's not necessarily hard to follow,
Happy Death Day 2U clearly doesn't want the
audience to linger too much on the how of
its storytelling, breezing through plot points
faster than you can say "wait, what?"
After being shot through spacetime to relive
her birthday loop in a whole other dimension,
Tree is faced with two tasks.
The first goal is to return to her own reality,
a course of action which she can't immediately
decide if she wants to take, considering that
her mother is still alive in this new world.
But her second goal of stopping the time loop
is something she has to achieve no matter
what, regardless of which reality she decides
to stay in.
The problem is that Sissy is a work-in-progress,
a powerful machine that neither Ryan nor his
lab mates yet entirely understand.
In order to get it under their control, they
need to do more research — lots of research.
Each time the loop resets, they lose their
progress, with the memories of everyone but
Tree being reset to the state they were in
when the loop started.
As a result, Tree is forced to become the
team's institutional memory, keeping track
of the complex quantum mechanics that make
the machine work.
It's a tall task and a battle of inches, with
the team only making progress thanks to Tree
resetting the loop by offing herself, elaborately
and hilariously, over and over again.
The three killers
Complicating all of this quantum confusion
is the inconvenient fact that, just like the
first movie, there's a killer on the loose.
In the first film, the Babyface masked killer
is portrayed by two characters — Tree's
sorority sister Lori, and a serial killer
named John Tombs, whom Lori sets up to frame
for Tree's death.
In the first movie's reality, Lori was motivated
to kill Tree out of jealousy due to her romantic
relationship with Gregory Butler, a married
professor and medical doctor whom Lori wanted.
The doe-eyed nice girl was a most unexpected
villain, making for a satisfying twist when
she's actually innocent in the second world.
So who's killing people in Happy Death Day
2U?
The sequel features three characters wielding
knives behind the Baby mask.
For the most part, the killings in the second
world are being committed by Dr. Butler himself,
as well as — shockingly — his wife Stephanie,
who seems to have been driven insane by Gregory's
infidelity.
While the two at first appear to be in cahoots
with each other, that doesn't really hold
up after Gregory decides to shoot Stephanie
during the movie's climax.
In this reality, they're apparently both just
crazy, and seem to totally deserve each other.
What a shame that it doesn't work out.
The third killer only appears in the movie's
first act, while Ryan is experiencing his
own time loop on September 19th — and the
reveal is a weird one.
One of the weirdest threads in Happy Death
Day 2U is the idea that the Babyface killer
pursuing Ryan in the movie's opening is actually
another version of himself, invading the first
Ryan's reality to stop him from causing the
time loops in the first place.
It's a tantalizing reveal to kick off the
movie's second act, promising doppelgängers,
evil twins, and intertwining timelines that
the movie just doesn't follow up on.
If you thought you missed something, well,
you didn't.
Despite that lack of a firm explanation, the
second Ryan seems to be from the future, possessing
knowledge about the time loop's effects that
no one beyond Tree should really have yet.
As much as it seems like this plot development
could be a setup for Tree's own doppelgänger
being the killer in dimension two, that's
not the case.
In fact, Tree is explicitly told that there
aren't two of her in dimension two.
When Tree goes to the second universe, she
replaces herself in it.
Despite the precedent set by a second Ryan,
an alternate version of Tree never shows up.
So how did Ryan end up with two copies of
himself running around?
There are many possibilities — but in the
movie itself, there are no answers.
Happy Death Day 2U seems to end on a cheerful
note of Tree returning to her own reality,
the time loop broken, and all of her hard-earned
progress in life restored.
But the world of the movie gets blown wide-open
in an out-of-left-field mid-credits sequence,
which takes the sci-fi aspects of the sequel
and goes all the way with them.
The scene begins with Tree and her co-conspirators
doing campus clean-up as punishment for their
reality-shattering lab work, the destructive
effects of which the faculty can only begin
to imagine.
But just because the Dean is in the dark about
the time machine's capabilities doesn't mean
everyone is.
Out of nowhere, the students are approached
by a fleet of dark-suited special agent types
from DARPA, a real-life federal research agency.
The agents promptly transport the students
to their headquarters, where they've set up
the confiscated Sissy machine.
It's revealed that the agency wants to do
their own research with the machine, but they
need the students' know-how in order to make
it work.
They also need a suitable test subject for
a new time loop of their own creation.
As Carter points out, what they're proposing
is a sadistic experience that no one deserves
to be put through — except maybe Danielle,
who ends the movie waking up and screaming,
apparently caught in her own time loop.
The ending of Happy Death Day 2U marks a wild
shift in tone that the sequel has spent its
whole runtime building to, setting up a third
movie in a way few could have anticipated.
We're not just theory-crafting, either writer-director
Chris Landon and producer Jason Blum have
already said they intend to make a third movie,
with the likelihood of it happening all depending
on the box office performance of Happy Death
Day 2U.
As Blum explained in an interview with CinePOP,
the genre-twisting nature of 2U is totally
intentional.
Blum said,
"I've never seen a franchise where one movie
is a certain genre and the next movie is a
different genre.
And that's certainly the case with Happy Death
Day and Happy Death Day 2U, and hopefully
if we make a third one it'll be a different,
third kind of genre."
While horror fans may be disappointed in the
series leaving behind its slasher roots, it's
hard not to be interested in where this story
could go.
Landon teased a potential third movie by saying
he has what feels like, quote, "a really bonkers,
fun idea.”
If audiences turn out for the weirdness of
Happy Death Day 2U, then we might get the
chance to see the series go full-bore nutso
in the next and final chapter.
Is it possible that this movie was designed
with loose ends that can be tied up later,
from the mid-credits shocker to the mysterious
second Ryan?
It certainly seems that way — and if the
threequel gets the greenlight, we can't wait
to see where the story goes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.